Film Courage: I’ve been reading this book
called LOL [LOL: From Homeless to Multimillion-dollar
Global Business Leader] The writer is Christy
Dreiling.
It’s about her life growing up impoverished
and then she became a multi-million dollar
salesperson and vice-president of a company.
She talked about what she learned was the
poverty mentality versus people who break
out of that, which [comes from] a willingness
to find a solution.
That people who stay in a poverty mentality,
don’t [find a solution] and those who break
out, they find solutions.
They have a problem, they find a solution.
That being said, people creating opportunities
for themselves, in Los Angeles as a writer.
It doesn’t even have to be in LA.
But those who don’t and say “I don’t
know what to do?
I’ve been submitting [and nothing].”
Whatever, versus those who find a way out
of that problem.
What have you noticed?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: Well I think what you
are saying is true.
Let’s face it, we can’t have it all!
We can’t be perfect in every single area.
And I think one of the things you were talking
about earlier, we were talking about how there
are differences in how things are done in
the industry now.
And one of the things is there are a lot more
people who are in career counseling as consultants.
And sometimes when you get stuck and especially
with writers are so internal about how they
process things and sometimes it’s hard to
be external and get things out there and to
do it the right way.
I know that there are people who are career
counselors who have really helped in that
area.
They talk to you and try to find out what
it is about you that is special and what is
it about your writing that is meaningful and
they try to bring that out of you and for
you to try to use that and to help you with
your work.
And I think that this is something that writers
can look into.
Not just writers, but I know actors and actresses
have to go to career coaches to help them
out with that.
You would think with actors and actresses
that they would be very external and very
‘out there.’
But a lot of actors and actresses that I’ve
met, there’s a lot of self-doubt sometimes
behind them.
And so every once and a while, they get stuck
and they sometimes go to career coaches to
help them out.
So there are career coaches who are specialists
in terms of writing.
Film Courage: Let’s say somebody at this
point can’t afford that.
What are some other things people can do to
create an opportunity for themselves?
Sounds like a writing group or any type of
creative group?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: A writing group is wonderful.
The more people you communicate with who are
doing the same thing you are doing means more
opportunities because I’ve noticed that
if one person finds a little bit of success,
they are willing to share it.
Like if they can get an agent or if they get
a producer to read their material, they are
then ready to say “Oh?
Well, maybe then I can help this person who
has a project that maybe that producer is
looking for.”
As I mentioned earlier, that’s what happened
to one of my clients when she was in a writer’s
group.
So I think that really does help.
I also think that if you go to different (in
terms of networking) networking groups that
they have here in LA.
There is one that is the first Friday of each
month and I think it is called First Friday
or something?
But they have a group where people get together
and they will say we are meeting at such and
such (and usually it’s a cocktail bar or
some group or restaurant).
And a lot of times there are other writers
there.
There are also other writers who have made
it, who were in that group who sometimes come.
There are things like that.
Somebody else I know said that when they first
moved here, they knew no one.
What they did was they Googled “Screenwriter
Meetup” and they came up with a list of
things and she went to every single one of
those.
She formed her own writer’s group from the
people who were of interest to her that she
felt she made a connection with.
She now has a lot of friends.
She came knowing no one.
She’s from North Dakota.
And she said there was nobody in her town.
She put up a little thing saying “Any screenwriters?”
She put it up at the local University in her
town.
And there is nobody there who said anything
about “Yeah, they are interested in screenwriting.”
So she said “I guess I need to move to California.”
And so she just took a leap of faith and she
did that.
I mean it doesn’t work for everybody but
it sure worked for her.
She now has an agent, she’s been doing punch-ups.
She’s a great comedy writer.
And so she’s been doing punch-ups and she’s
been doing some stuff for late night comedy
work to do writing there.
It’s kind of interesting to see how people
start to make slow progress just by the connections
that they are making.
Film Courage: I think we all know someone
who has great intentions but they just kind
of wait for emails, they wait by the phone
and they don’t do anything about it.
What have you seen in that sort of type that
gets them out where they can stop waiting
and relying on someone else and making opportunities.
Like the woman who started her own Meetup
group, which is an excellent idea.
But that’s kind of scary?
That takes a leap of…I mean I get it, she
knew some of the people [previously] but that’s
intimidating?
What do you see?
Kathie Fong Yoneda: She told me the most intimidating
thing was moving from North Dakota to California.
Film Courage: Sure, that’s scary in itself.
Kathie Fong Yoneda: It was scary, but she
told me if she could do that, she had nothing
to lose.
She looked at it like when she went to these
Meetup groups, she knew nobody.
She had nothing to lose and everything to
gain.
And I think a lot of it is your attitude when
you come in.
If you are looking for something and you really
want it, you make the effort to let somebody
get to know you better.
And it does, it takes a huge leap of faith.
But it’s worthwhile in the long run for
people who do put themselves out there.
It’s not easy but you have to do that.
There are a lot of people who just give up.
And if they give up, to me it means it wasn’t
meant for you.
But if you stick with it, something is eventually
going to happen.
Like I told you, I interviewed over 200 of
these people who are professional writers.
The average was 8 scripts.
There was one guy who is now on staff on television.
He’s a really good television writer.
And I asked him “Well, gosh?
How does it feel?”
You know how many scripts it took him?
It took him 12 scripts.
And I said “Well what did you do when you
reached 8 scripts?”
And he said “I don’t know.
There was just something about…I could not
stop.
It became like “I’m going to do this”
And he just had to do it.
And he kept writing and writing and he finally
got to that 12th script and I said “Gee,
I’d like to read some of those first 10
scripts.”
And he said “No…I don’t think you want
to.”
And I said “Yeah, but I’d like to see
what they were like.”
And he said “You know what, I don’t let
anybody read them.”
And I said “Well do you still have them?”
And he said “Yeah, I have them in a drawer
at the bottom of my desk.”
And I said “Well, why are you keeping them
then?”
And he said “It’s to keep me humble.
Because how could I even think?
I look at those 10 and say how could I even
think I was a writer when I read those 10
scripts?”
I mean it just amazed me!
And this guy is quite successful.
I mean, he makes 6 figures a year as a writer
and he’s doing quite well, but it took him
that long.
And so you have to have that determination,
you just have to have to do it.
You can’t just say “Oh, well.
It’s not going to happen.”
It’s like…I always tell people…it’s
like you’re knocking at Hollywood’s door.
They ain’t going to answer…you are not
going to open that door if you don’t give
them the answers or if you don’t tell them
what it is that you want.
And it’s not just what you want, you have
to show them what you have.
So want and have are two different things.
You know, you can dream about it, but you
have to make the dream come true.
Dreaming about it and not doing anything about
it, that’s the difference between success
and failure.
And some of the people who I’ve seen that
I’ve known for years who are doing quite
well in the business, it’s because they
deserved it, they really stuck to it.
They just couldn’t help themselves.
They just had to keep writing.
And they believed in themselves that they
said “I’ve just got to do this.”
A lot of times they had to take two or three
jobs in order to do it.
A lot of times family and marriage came and
went in between all of that because I asked
one of them one time…his wife was a teacher
and they had twins and so he had to be the
one to stay home with the twins, which is
not easy.
And I asked him “How did you do it and get
your assignments in on time?”
And he said he basically had to stay up at
night.
He would set the alarm, he would go to sleep
at 10 o’clock, he would get up at 3 o’clock
in the morning, do the feeding, and then he
would work for three hours straight.
And he gave himself that he would have to
write so many words or how many scenes or
whatever it is and that’s how he did it.
He just stuck to it.
And he said there were times where he would
just sit there and he would be waiting and
waiting for those words to just come and they
wouldn’t.
And he finally just started writing down just
random words and pretty soon (he said) he
would just come across something.
It was like “Oh, wait a minute?
That word.”
And pretty soon it would start to flow.
And he said he doesn’t understand it to
this day, he just knows it happened.
And he said that’s what he did but he always
made sure even in those times when he felt
like he couldn’t do it, if he wasn’t going
to write he was going to sit there and stare
at the page and just write random words until
something came to him.
Because he felt he had to at least psychically
be doing it, or psychically typing it up for
him to be able to feel that “Okay, even
if I am not sitting here with an idea, I’m
just going to keep typing until something
strikes me.”
That’s literally how he said he got some
of his assignments done.
Some of it was trash, you know.
He would type for an hour and nothing would
come up and then all of the sudden something
would click.
So I think he just felt that he had to do
it, he forced himself to do it.
It worked for him and he had the weirdest
hours but it worked for him.